du arsch was machst du mal im haus ich
weiß ja house party gemacht eigentlich
mit eingeladen du kannst ja zur nächsten
komme also da habe ich ja kein problem
mit hallöchen meine lieben freunde und
herzlich willkommen zu einer neuen folge
lost
wir waren das jetzt mal dabei stehen
geblieben dass wir hier dieses als blöd
dass wir das letzte mal dass hier
ausprobiert haben mit der kommission ist
so gut dass wir das letzte mal dass sie
ausprobiert haben mit der monster falle
wie ich das hier ein wenig bauen wollte
da habe ich mir schon ein paar aufbau
gemacht keine ordnung und da wollen
jetzt einfach mal weitermachen weil ich
gerade immens bock auf aufnehmen
also haben wir alle sachen damit kann
jetzt endlich direkt da unten hin gehen
wenn aber kurz davor mir noch mehr
einmal zu machen weil deren ich nehme
ich lasse es einfach mal so wir könnten
nämlich eigentlich schon direktorin
gehen aber am liebsten würde die lava
dort und nicht irgendwo lagern und ich
glaube das mache ich auch ich lager
die lava so und ab auf die leiter runter
dann werden die ganze mops hierher
getrieben fallen hier dann runter fallen
dann hier noch mal in den wasserfluss
rein so und den werden wir nun bauen
also die feinde dann schon mal noch mal
fünf blöcke runter wie ich sagen was ist
jetzt 33
45 ich weiß nicht gar nicht wie groß ist
das bauen werde diesen abschluss das
heißt mach das jetzt einfach mal hier
bei leisen noch einen tiefer ja ich
glaube das müsse reichen so steine
nämlich auch mal steine damit einfach
gut aussieht so nur mir jetzt muss ich
wissen wo ungefähr mein haus ist scheiße
war dass die noch die neben musik dass
die leiter dass mein haus das heißt ich
muss das dahin bauen
das ist jetzt nur noch ein paar
feinheiten die muss man nicht unbedingt
beachten
aber der fluss möchte ich gerne dahin
haben damit ich möglichst die monster
nahe bei mir dann raus raus kommen habe
damit ich einfach nur nachher seinen
gang zu diesem gang zu dem gang sag ich
mal ganz zu diesem ding hier bauen muss
ich hab jetzt natürlich keine schaufel
dabei auch gut so also auf jeden fall
habe ich euch dass ihr eine letzten
folge gezeigt nicht mehr das ungefähr
vorgestellt habe ich habe allerdings
auch kein holz dabei auch klar da kann
ich mir nicht mehr so magath damals
jetzt wieder hoch naja ich mach das
einfach so per hand weiter die monster
schwimmen dann quasi hier so hehr und
gehen dann nachher in die falle also in
diese lava hatte das muss dann drei
wochen hier und da bin ich mir gar nicht
so sicher ob ich das alles so hinkriege
weil das ja doch alles sehr eng ist und
ich hab noch nie der monster falle so im
survival mode gebaut also bisher
komplett es egal weil wenn man mal ein
lava geflogen ist oder so also wartet
mal ganz kurz 123 und wartet das wäre da
starten 2 3 4 5 6 7 8
dann wird da neues wasser anfangen
als ob wir das ist jetzt vier breit ist
das heißt theoretisch müsste ich dann
auch einzelne wand gehen hier private
einzel mittels zack da musste ich sogar
noch nie bei der anderen seite dann auch
noch mal eine wanderroute mir passt ein
bisschen passt das schon so wessels
natürlich blöd dass ich mache mir gleich
einfach nur die schaufel als ich hoffe
meine schaufel auch unter der rüstung
hätten eine vernünftige machen
aber nein wir müssen sparen an allen
grenzen im moment total wenig eisen weil
in der die würde weite tal klein das
heißt wir müssen noch mal jemand eine
neue hülle gehen so hier komm' machen
weiter team per hand jeder das ist ja
nicht haben sehr damit auch alle gemacht
damals im guten alten mittelalter als zu
den zeiten unter karl dem großen und
augustus und napoleon war die strecke
wieder hand mit der bloßen hand
mitgenommen
als sie damals minecraft gespielt haben
so also was kommt jetzt ist raus solche
kommt wasser raus dann bisher dann quasi
falle das heißt hier bleibt erstmal so
stein und links und rechts kommen da
diese fehler die ich gerade in der
letzten folge da oben gebaut habe
auch schöner spitzhacke ich glaube das
geht ungefähr gleich schnell oder hatte
guckt mal dass dort doch bisschen länger
okay gut und zwar muss ich da jetzt gar
nicht so bündigen hinsetzen und zwar
kann ich glaube dort nämlich einfach
direkt daran setzen in die wand
schließlich braucht es gar nichts am
töten behälter bauen und da ist wieder
ganz zur erde soll
so also das heißt wenn da wasser ist
dann musste er theoretisch dahin da da
da nicht da definitiv nicht sondern auf
der anderen seite dann auch hier mache
ich mir einfach noch kopflos sondern mit
ein bisschen schön aussieht weil das
wird nachher so die ecke sein die ich
mir selber dann noch so angucke und dann
muss wiederum da da und da packe ich dir
nachher da rein und dann dürfte
eigentlich nichts passieren so dann
kommt da da da ich kann ja gut höre ich
kann essen
hh du kriegst mich nie lava mir passiert
schon nichts mehr passiert schon nichts
mehr passiert schon nichts du macht euch
keine sorgen aber ich mein gibt auch das
essen aus
das war mein letztes brot wenn jetzt
schon der größte lappe
so richtig platziert
beim zweiten jetzt blöd dass diese
blöden leiter noch einfach so blöden
radios jahren so
denn
die leiter der abgebrannte
jetzt mal ernsthaft ami dessen
abgebrannt
die leiter muss die weiterhin die stalin
gesetzt habe
in den wert habe ich erhöhe verstehe ich
nicht naja egal also da fließen dann
also muss ja auch noch
ich brauche übrigens auch wasser das
kann jetzt von oben erstmal holen um die
fackeln hierhin gebt mir wasser
ich hoffe dass es jetzt da so noch
etliche quelle hier
so nun seht her und staune ich packe
jetzt einfach mal rein und da und ich
hoffe das passiert nix superclocked
selbst wenig die mobs bla bla bla bla
bla hier kann nichts gegen machen daher
fliegen sie das schon mal gegen und dann
gehen sind da dann wieder runter dann
fliegen da dann so um die kurve und da
fliegen dann die items er nachher und
das ist nicht richtig cool so dann haben
wir eigentlich schon fertig nur da muss
natürlich noch weiterhin das heißt wir
müssen doch mal nach hier unten man
jetzt hierher nach falsche richtung da
ist die leiter was muss ich jetzt
eigentlich noch holen ich muss noch eine
leiter holen noch eine schaufel dann
können wir das ganze ding hier schon
anschmeißen also dann alle fackeln
wegnehmen hamburg hat eigentlich schon
fertig und es ist nacht toll ist
natürlich blöd war ich das denn jetzt
ich kann er theoretisch durch diesen
ausgang in meinem haus allerdings ist
mein haus von innen noch nicht
ausgeleuchtet
das heißt es wird eine gewisse gefahr
darstellen dort alles gut werde es wohl
nicht so alles gut nach vorne verdammt
blöd man auch dass der hund ok cool
schön dass du mir so gut hilft und so
hier setzt keine frage hin so und wir
müssen jetzt unbeschadet unserem an die
sonne geht gerade auf ok das ist gut
sagt wir können jetzt einfach hier
verankern so hund kommt herein
ich hoffe mal dass nichts passiert
ich brauche erst mal was zu essen du
auch nachher kriegst aber nicht so schön
brötchen und ne was siehst du hören gar
nichts man jetzt muss sicher ist so blöd
dass man brote einfach nicht stecken
konnten ich meine was machten das ein
unterschied ob man die stecken kann oder
nicht gar kein richtig hey guck mal ich
war beim bäcker weiterkommen du kannst
auch ein braver und ach so die habe ich
mir selber ach so du kannst kein brot
essen und das ist aber schade so gut ich
wollte mir holzholen 6 beziehungsweise 6
bzw
da stecke ich würde mir schaufeln machen
schaufeln brauchte ich was brauche ich
denn noch was heute noch mal steine
wollte auf jeden fall mit dem glaube ich
aber genug von dem ich so einen raum
machen kann nachher eine leiter eine
leiter es sind zwei chips und flips da
ja schön braver hund brav breath brass
so und nun werden wir die monster falle
hier vervollständigen sachsen hin
ach das ist schon der weg den ich damals
gebaut habe ach stimmt dann wäre ich
aber noch anders bauen müssen
klappt das denn jetzt alles so also das
haus ist in der richtung das heißt hier
ist die leiter das heißt in die richtung
müsste das eigentlich alles gehen
denn das erst mal da stehen ja das passt
aber okay gut
das heißt die mobs gehen die runter bla
bla bla bla bla so fall ist werde ich
das hier gehen da rein so zac blabla den
wassereimer allerdings da packe ich noch
mal ganz kurz
wie komme ich denn jetzt da drunter her
ohne das jetzt eben die sterbe an der
kann eigentlich nicht passieren welche
hier im wasser bin okay gut ist kommt
weg dann führt das hier wieder zusammen
okay das ist gut ankommen ich hier die
alters an
hier können wir dann theoretisch noch so
eine glaswand machen damit weder dann so
ein bisschen mehr zu gucken können
ich hoffe ich bin jetzt einfach bei
jedem stein richtig vorsichtig damit
sicherlich noch etwas abbauen was
eventuell zufalle gehört dann kommen die
items halt hier an
dann habe ich hier so einen raum hat mal
waren die fenster hier waren die fenster
das heißt ich so einen raum auf der höhe
und meine spitze des kaputt und ich
stopp dass hier mal ganz kurzen moment
ich brauchte unseren hof step am besten
ich habe jetzt auch keinen crafting
table mit einer egal da sind die ganzen
mops dann und die alten kommen dann
genau dort an und das müsste doch
eigentlich alles funktionieren so wie
ich mir das alles vorstellen
ich brauche halt noch fans also glas was
ich jetzt gerade auf vergessen habe so
da muss noch blocken
weil nur die items halt dadurch sollen
und mehr auch nicht dann baue ich mich
jetzt welche einfach hoch aber da habe
ich angst dass ich jetzt er ich bin
hundertprozentig unter sand und das
daneben die sterbe aber erstmal muss der
raum noch ein bisschen größer
und ich muss mich kurz gerade hinsetzen
so nicht dass man rücken nach einem
schiff ist meine damen und herren so ich
glaube viel größer aber auch gar nicht
nur ich mache hier unten anhalt die
ganzen kisten denn für das ganze
die ganzen drops von den monstern damit
ich das nicht immer alles hochschleppen
muss weil ich denke da wird schon der
menge an kommen hier merkte ich quatsche
weniger weil ich jetzt einfach hier
ganzen abbauen und das eine totale
nennen wäre hier so alles fertig das
heißt wir können jetzt die eigentlich
eine treppe hoch bauen
ich werde das einfach mal zwei hof
machen
damit ich mich im notfall nicht immer so
rüber bauen kann wartet man also ich
brauche ich dann quasi die hoch und da
ist wasser alter wie kann das denn bitte
sein
ach scheiße damit wieder unter dem arm
an fakten nicht als unter dem abfluss
alles jetzt natürlich blöd und es regnet
gerade um na toll und jetzt hab ich auch
noch wasser hingesetzt super wir dann
geht der abschluss wartete da geht
darunter das heißt das ist aber gar
nicht so lange eigentlich kann doch
eigentlich gar nicht so lang sein
könnten ja theoretisch auch
sonnenaufgang einfach da sie durch die
mitte nach oben machen aber den winter
natürlich kenne er auch blödsinn wie
oder was wir auch machen können ist ganz
einfach hatte dagegen dass ein rein
damit ist alles sehr schön symmetrisch
ist aber dafür braucht natürlich eine
menge glas für das was ich jetzt vorhat
alter der regen ist echt laut
so ist jetzt erstmal eine fackel hin da
und zwar dass wir wirklich hierher gehen
und uns dann hier hoch gerade jetzt in
der quasi die sportflächen dass man
durch die sportflächen durchgeht damit
einfach man auch ein bisschen was sieht
und dann mache ich das halt voll mit
glas sag ich mal
immerhin ist das auf jeden fall zwei
klingen muss gar nicht zwar egal
damit man auch ein bisschen was sieht
von diesem kompletten koloss hier aber
es müsste schon da sein
hey da kam ich mir jetzt gerade wieder
total falschen tag wieder total problem
ich müsste doch eigentlich schon längst
auf diesem blöden spawn flächen seien
erwarte ich hab dir ach ich hab das
letzte hoch gebaut das stimmt jetzt
bestimmt auch lange suchen und zwar dass
wir dann einfach er mit seiner glasröhre
sage ich mal dadurch gehen und an uns
immer anschauen können was dann alles so
stimmt ganz witzig nachher guckt da sind
wir auch schon
sollten wir da ist dann die leiter nach
her und da muss ich mich dann hoch bauen
hoffmann ich dachte verliert schon der
sand unter meine spitzhacke es kaputt
toll so da müssen dann weiter runter gut
dann würde ich sagen kriegen wir sogar
vielleicht in dieser folge noch die
monsterwelle endlich mal fertig
und jetzt vonn glaube ich sogar monster
oder weil so ein richtiges gewitter hier
das wäre cool wenn minecraft anwenden so
alles ein bisschen nach xinjiang fackeln
läuft nicht mehr so viel leuchten sag
ich mal da sind noch sechs ringe bis
unwetter
endlich muss doch aus jedem immer ein
regal das fertig ist nicht völlig egal
schön gut was wollte ich jetzt endlich
holen paar brote kirchner dabei ein tun
alter die box ist fast komplett voll nur
mit dingen smit cobblestone iron dass
ich erstmal jeder blieben zwei boote mit
die beiden wassereimer auch glas wollte
ich machen und dafür brauche ich zeit
und kohle
die soll nämlich jetzt die womit das
heißt zack zack zack da ein stack da ein
weg
1 tag habe ich den ofen das ist ein
kleiner trick hier vom profi ok ich kann
mir nicht wirklich so scheiße der trick
war noch falsch aber ich warne
spitzhacke dafür ist dass viele richtig
zu machen ich bin ich blöd man
jay zwei glas glas drei glas je ein
klares ja ein glas elf die erste das
keinen fall reichen so dass auch einen
dingens schlager immer noch ein bisschen
mehr kommt darin er da kommt darin wurde
auch wenn jeder von euch doch noch
so nice
zack zack zack jetzt haben eine
spitzhacke der spitzhacke kommen jetzt
diesen rufen jahr born und daran hofen
höfen nicht übereinander platzieren kann
wer das nun einfach so und das ist jetzt
ganz klub damit haben jetzt den crafting
table abgedeckt denen wir nun gar nicht
mehr ausfüllen und dieser regen der
nervt auch überhaupt nicht ich sehe
nicht mehr die sonne
aufzuregen
entwickler sind bogners was brauche ich
denn noch was braucht dich sonst noch
etwas
oder reicht das sogar schon ein glas ich
es gar nicht können ja einfach mal
gucken und leiter und auf jeden fall
leitern stimmen leitern weiterhin
weiteren und hier könnte ich auch mal
welchen da was mit die kelle
da sind stickies und ich habe selber
noch steht
dieses ganz toll wir drücken ihm einen
kompletten handy kaputt
nee das intersport ruhig dachte jetzt
ist es genug so 32 leiter müssten
eventuell reichen auch schon noch ein
bisschen glas
das glas müsste auch erst mal reichen
das heißt wir kennen jetzt die arbeiten
uns erstmal unser haus chillen und ich
glaube es ist ja auch so
in dieser version dass wenn man ein kind
das dann der regen aufhört oh gott und
setzen auf einmal ein monster gespannt
jeder achte sieht sich gar nicht wo ich
für eine spende
alternativ ist richtig nach ag weg geh
weg geh weg hilfe ist die spinne da ich
weiß nicht ob ich jetzt getrost ein
schaffen kann ohne dass irgend welche
monster hier reinkommen war auch gut so
aufhört zu regnen
borgas wittmann branche und ein
einschlag und war kein ganz paula sind
das stärke auch nicht ich brauche ganz
für tnt
das kann man noch mal mit federn machen
ach ja hier fehle hier und hier müssen
wir abbauen verlauf da haben wir
abgebrochen weil wir da ja genau stimmt
die kurzrennen wie went into höhle gut
aber es kann ja eh noch momente machen
und zwar monster falle an sich also
gestern eigentlich gleich schon fertig
also ich glaub ich hoffe das auch in
dieser aufnahme ich muss natürlich erst
mal wieder ein bisschen die ganze
fackeln wegnehmen so was alles dann
lasse ich erst mal so eine kleine
generalprobe laufen und das müsste dann
eigentlich sogar klappen
ich kann er dann auf den gang der hinten
gemacht habe irgendwie mit meinem gang
verbinden oder so bin ich schon so habe
also den ich mir halt schon runter
gegraben achten wenn ihr versteht was
ich meine
ich baue santa pola ich mich was kann
den vierbeinern wenn man einfach so
sandabbau im kreis läuft naja so gut ich
zeige euch mal ganz kurz wie ich mir das
gedacht habe den eingang haben
eigentlich direkt schon zu machen hier
den hier macht jetzt aber eben 8 or go
the [ __ ] ich wunder mich eher warum geht
das nicht zu so der eingang ist zu das
heißt wir können nur noch hierdurch
darein gut wenn wir dann da reingehen
dass da unten kann ich erst mal alles zu
bauen weil das bringt mir gar nichts
mehr hier weil man jetzt wo ich da den
stein ab und gart paradies ist dieses
alte minecraft ist echt witzig teilweise
und jetzt fällt mir auf dass ich gar
keine steine mehr haben um mit ihnen
wieder wieder hoch zu bauen
schön luca muss ich mir unseren raum
anlegen damit ich mir steine damit die
steine habt zum hoch bauen ein 23 mal
noch zwei starke 923 perfekt so und zwar
meine ich dass wir uns dann hier runter
gehen dann gehen wir hierher sag ich mal
da machen wir das allerdings auch noch
alles aus glas ach jetzt euro
ich habe keinen plan was da unten ist
aber ich will doch ehrlich gesagt nicht
herausfinden weil das die zu krass tief
aus naja also die hauptsache ist jetzt
erstmal dass wir die monster falle ihnen
die noch schnell fertig kriegen und
diese ganzen ärzte hindern uns daran
alter schon wieder so eine lange kohle
alle die kein ende nimmt
und hier geht noch weiter und das lava
das ist ja gleich irgendwas glatt und
schießt mich rein und ich bin selber so
blöd und finther alter die steine sind
die von mir da ist ich hoffe mal die
sind von mir denn da jetzt noch einen
mops vorne ist eine trasse aus das wäre
so geil so hier ist aber erst mal fertig
da können wir später immer noch
irgendwann gucken was da so los ist
okay gut warte ich guck mal ganz kurz
von dieser seite hier das ist ein
bisschen besser man jetzt auch noch die
fackeln und alles aufsaugen das mit also
jetzt mal raus gekommen
das heißt man irgendwie hier direkt
schon dran so dann mache ich da so den
gang so das mache ich dann hier so alles
aus glas da kommen dann wieder
cobblestone hin als ich denke ihr
versteht immer mehr so was ich meine
beziehungsweise kann ich das ja auch
einfach aus cobbelsdorf machen und nur
diese röhrig aus glas bzw
nur so die ränder sowie fenster so
fenster artig nur dafür bräuchte
keystone und jetzt fehlt es mir an
koppel store nicht glaubt sehr wohl
nicht naja das leben ist manchmal hart
ich höre schon wieder über es gilt diese
wie so hörcher skelette da bei meinem
haus ich verstehe das nicht
ich hab noch drei und 44 leitern ist
auch kraß schönen haben jetzt aber hier
schon sondern eingang sag ich mal
nein die leute ist runtergefallen
aus und vorbei
dann haben wir jetzt mal alleingang hier
direkt runter dann haben wir hier
komplett glas sag ich mal
damit man da auch schön rein gucken kann
in diesem mob falle locken schön freut
mich
nicht dass wir das jetzt so hingekriegt
haben wir alle zusammen
okay das mache ich mir noch nicht ganz
zurecht daher vielleicht gleich noch
durch muss da weiß ich jetzt allerdings
gerade nicht wie ich da runter kommen
sollte außer mit einem wassereimer
vielleicht weil wir dann wieder
hochkriegen keine ahnung ich mache es
einfach mal von unten jetzt hier
hey du kannst unten aber an so sieht das
doch schon mal ganz gut aus diese blöde
aus wartet sind da noch in welche blöcke
die kann ja schon mal weg nehmen da ist
keiner
und hier ist auch keiner denke ich auch
keine ich erst mal wieder so ein
brötchen am ländernamen und je sechs de
bug jetzt falsch an
auch gut ich kann ich wieder mitnehmen
weil ihn brauche ich eh nicht so warte
hier schlechter mutter die leiter kann
ich die räte schon ab das mache ich
nachher mein gott und
da kriegt man auch keinen fall schaden
dass auch eigentlich ganz gut so wenn
mir die alten lasst mich hier durch
wasser gut dass jetzt der raum auf soll
hierbei auch noch rechnet man die
fackeln
so wollte ich ja auch noch glas machen
was wir von eingefallen ist sicher dass
er auch einfach so machen können hieß
den ganzen items darein einfach so dann
kommen die da quasi schon so gut
das müsste es dann eigentlich gewesen
sein von dem monster falle also grob
jetzt muss ich hier noch irgendwie
hochkommen natürlich baut das mal so ich
baue die fackeln einfach mal rein das
musste man ja damals zu machen damit man
da hier die treppen hoch bei unterm
stein und wieder leitern ort falsche sei
egal mein gott sei nicht schlimm
so sei es theoretisch haben was ich darf
jetzt allerdings auch nicht allzu viel
ausleuchten damit nicht die da drin da
von ihm wie geschädigt werden oder so so
gut ich würde sagen wir fangen jetzt
einfach unten am leben ableuchten
ableuchten auch gut richtig angst ich
mach kurz auf kiesvorkommen wir machen
das jetzt alles hier unentschieden
ja direkt die leiter bei abbauen das ist
jetzt wieder seine seine arbeit jetzt
sondern einen runter und dann hier
wieder abbauen
und jetzt mal ganz behinderten also das
heißt keine beleidigung verhindert als
beleidigung wir nutzen das war jetzt
entschuldigen das web informieren so die
noch und ich auch noch dich nämlich
hubert und dass das ist peter peter ist
fünf jahre alt
er hängt die schon seit locker fünf
jahren stellt euch das mal vor meine
lieben kinder fünf jahre immer an der
gleichen stelle
das macht doch spaß klatschen wir alle
für peter klatt klatsch klatsch muss ich
hier überall her schwingen fackel nie
abreißen
alle scheiße jetzt sonne blöde monster
viel ausgedacht so ihr seht dann
wahrscheinlich gar nichts ich sie selber
fast gar nichts ich glaube im wasser
kann man nicht bauen oder also ich hoffe
es
bitte mit online ich habe da ganz sind
nur gott ich habe eine fackel vergessen
abzubauen
so schnell dorthin so jetzt ist hier
gleich auch das letzte licht aus
zugleich ist richtig dunkel hier
dann gehe ich nach unten dann gehe ich
durch die a9 wenn ich durch die falle
gehe ich bezog blöd dass sich die falle
da unten schon zugebaut habe das war
einfach so ein eigentor
vielleicht daher gleich wieder durch
muss ok und ist alles gut
hier unten das licht mache ich auch mal
weg
ich weiß nicht ob nicht nachher die
zombies einfach dann hier bleiben oder
ob die automatische nicht ob da nicht
einfach auch noch mache ich einfach auch
noch weiterhin dann sollte das er
eigentlich überhaupt nichts passieren
dass die da also dass dieser dann auf
jeden reingehen kann ich nicht ob das
jetzt einfach kein leiter mangel tableau
ach ich bin so zack zack so das haben
wir fertig jetzt noch oben alle fackeln
wegnehmen dann ist die monster fall an
sich finde ich boah alter was bin ich
froh dass wir dieses megaprojekt er dich
fertig haben also diese monster falle
zumindest wollen wir sind schon siebten
los partners muss man sich mal geben das
ist richtig viel also sieben parts jetzt
erst mal wenig an welcher der partner
dreiviertelstunde
das ist schon eine gewisse anzahl
eigentlich was richtig und klug jetzt
hier das alles schon abzubauen
aber ich glaube bei tags bond ja erst
mal nicht so viel
bisher bin ich schon richtig nervös
nicht das gleiche wie ein zombie von mir
spontan creeper noch besser aber
eigentlich müsste das komplette prinzip
doch so funktionieren oder als ich meine
dass ihr monaten abbauen
ja ich weiß jetzt noch schönheits
arbeiten vornehmen können aber es ist
eigentlich ganz gut geworden
ihr seht schon richtig dass ein bisschen
zittern bin so das kann man eigentlich
auch zu machen weil lava quelle brauchen
wir vorerst nicht euro das sind jetzt
die letzten fackeln 1 234 da liegt noch
eine gruppe freunde oro alle die jetzt
gerade zu gucken ich bin so ein zittern
etwas und das band auch schon das erste
auftakt schnell weg hier steht eine
fackel
okay die komme ich natürlich alle zu mir
aber die sommer nach unten gehen
und da drin veranstalten ihr soll kinder
und neil ruhe oder habe ich das jetzt
vielleicht ein bisschen zu tief gebaut
ich weiß gar nicht kommt jetzt schon
irgendwas an
ich hätte vielleicht noch da wo ich die
ganzen abschlüsse gemacht habe könnte
ich ja theoretisch irgendwann mal noch
eines ponys etagen machen dass er jetzt
natürlich vergessen war ohne witz dass
wir drei jahre dauern dann mache ich
vielleicht mal ein mann mit dem ultimate
festmutter rein wenn sie überhaupt für
diese version gibt und mache mir dann
einfach seine hacke marketings keine
ahnung wäre das nennt so lange ein
monster hier runter geht hab ich schon
zufrieden irgendeines muss doch wurden
diese komischen abflüsse da tappen
ich meine in der beta des problems sind
die muss jetzt auch nicht besonders klug
naja aber wir haben gesehen dass
funktioniert eigentlich und die monster
um sind auch schon gespannt ich schaue
mir das noch mal ganz kurz da oben an
und dann mache ich auch wieder einen
stopp für heute denke ich erst mal
kennen wer ich bin echt richtig müde das
board auf jeden fall ordentlich was also
das skelett hallo
jetzt hat mich schon an fokussiert sonst
ich habe erstmal fast gar nichts naja ok
ist es nicht okay da ist richtig party
gerade ich schwimme ein damals in einer
höhle da es auf fakten komponenten mal
dabehalten hälfte homos geht dahin nimmt
man okay dass meine fanbase müsste
wissen
ihr seht meine fanbase
wahrscheinlichkeit kann ich guckt euch
das video bei nacht an und genau an
dieser stelle genau bei minute 40
ungefähr die beiden leute da die
verfolger schon die ganze zeit online
das wars thun in meinem haus du arsch
was machst du meinem haus ich weiß gibt
eine hausparty gemacht eigentlich nicht
eingeladen du kannst ja zur nächsten
kommt
da habe ich ja kein problem mit
so bitte kein zombie ich höre zombie
geräusche so sonst auch im dialog balu
dass eine spinne so bist du willst auf
mich ist es doch tag
wir sind auch tagsüber freunde so dass
seine fehler gut mein leben freuen ich
mache einen aufnahmestopp wir sind schon
wieder bei 40 minuten eigentlich wollte
ich folgen jetzt erstmal so bei einer
halben stunde lassen allerdings keine
ahnung ich glaube ihr freut euch auch
das ist alles ein bisschen länger dauert
die ganzen folgen also ich glaube dass
es freut euch oder video seite dagegen
naja egal ich würde mich definitiv
bisschen wer sich sagt dass man auch
nicht weil er hinten creepy mächtig noch
abschießen
ok coolen jetzt haben sogar ganz aber
ich habe nur noch einen pfeil
ok dann will ich sagen wenn ihr ihn
freunde das was jetzt erstmal mit lost
platz sieben
wir sind sehr weit schon gekommenen lost
möchte ich sagen wer meine monster falle
wir haben zwar noch keine diamanten aber
wir haben oder menschen diamanten noch
keine diamanten aber dafür schon ein
paar hallo ein paar nachbarn haben wir
gefunden
wie kommt dann immer noch ein haus drauf
keine ahnung als ich lass mir da schon
noch was einfallen dach kommt dann auch
noch hier alles und dann würde ich sagen
sie uns beim nächsten mal wenn euch das
video gefallen dann würde ich mich
definitiv über einen daumen hoch freuen
und wofür und ich sagen ja